[Music]
my name is max Pemberton I'm a doctor a
journalist and editor a spectator health
in recent years more and more the
government has looked to industry and
big business to help it deliver on
public health initiatives a key aspect
to this is it is in the interests of
business to diversify and innovate and
through this they will develop healthier
better products but can we really trust
businesses to innovate do they have a
duty to the public good or just to their
shareholders I want to explore where the
responsibilities lie for improving
people's health is it with the
government is it with individuals or is
it with industry to start off with I'm
going to speak to dr. Sarah Joris she's
an NHS GP and she's also on the medical
board for the charity drinks aware which
promotes sensible drinking Sarah one of
the policies that medicine has adopted
in recent years is that of harm
reduction
can you explain what actually means the
trouble is in an ideal world we'd love
it if everybody had the healthiest the
balanced diets with seven portions of
vegetable and fruit exercise for half an
hour five days a week was not remotely
overweight had never touched a cigarette
in their lives and drank two glasses of
wine a week it doesn't happen and it's
not going to happen
so unfortunately what we see is if we go
around banging on about how this is the
only way to live healthily then people
just say well I can't do that so much
well not bother effectively I think a
much more realistic way of doing it is
saying let's look at how we can help you
to make small changes and the classic
example was the guidance which came out
from nice on smoking where they were
talking not about smoking cessation and
about saying right there is only one way
to go we need to think as an alternative
about reducing tobacco related harm so
what we're talking to people about now
is alternatives there's a lot of
controversy about vaping and I don't
think there's any doubt that we don't
have enough proof
if it's ever going to be there to say it
is completely safe but what we do know
is that it's considerably less harmful
than smoking so therefore we've moved
from saying we're not going to recommend
it because we don't know if it's
completely safe to saying actually we
may not know it's completely safe but we
do know that you can considerably reduce
harm by switching from normal cigarettes
to vaping or by using nicotine
replacement therapy long term rather
than just using it for the short term
while you're trying to get off
cigarettes as a strategy how successful
has harm-reduction been if you look at
countries like say Finland where they
had a huge national push towards
reducing their incredibly high rate of
heart attack and stroke they managed to
cut the rate of heart attack and stroke
in Finland by two thirds over the course
of not more than a decade so 70 percent
of strokes and heart attacks gone almost
overnight
why because the government said you need
to do this you need to make dramatic
changes you need to jump and the
population said how high two works then
do you think business or industry should
be involved in public health initiatives
I think industry has an enormous ly
important part to play in public health
initiatives and the food industry is an
absolutely classic example of that in
the last 10 years the amount of salt in
tomato ketchup in the UK like the amount
of salt in cornflakes a few years
earlier has gone down considerably but
that's because every company has worked
together they've worked with Public
Health and they've done it very very
gradually so that the population hasn't
noticed it happening and we're now not
used to it you've been involved in drink
aware it's funded by the drinks industry
so why should we believe what it tells
us well from my perspective I worked
with it for a very long time I am aware
that in some other countries there has
been controversy about how closely their
countries drink aware has worked with
their government but they are completely
independent of ours all I can say to you
is as a member of the medical advisory
panel I have never been told what to do
I've never been told to change anything
that I do
and anything that we take to them they
take seriously to what extent do you
think that the individual should take
responsibility for their health versus
government or industry so yes people do
need to take responsibility but
unfortunately these are addictions and
in the NHS we do not nor should we
discriminate against people on the basis
of their life choices or whether their
illnesses are caused by their life
choices or by simple pedlar Sarah seems
really positive about the role that
industry has had in harm reduction she
still sees though the main thrust of
initiatives coming from government-owned
I want to know what the libertarian
perspective or Sam Bowman is executive
director of the Adam Smith Institute I
think tank that champions individual
choice I'm wary of placing the
responsibility wholly in industry
because some people would argue they're
often part of the problem to what extent
do you think they can also be part of
the solution I think we shouldn't be
expecting the industry to do this kind
of out of the goodness of their own
hearts really for them it's about profit
and that's actually a good thing there's
been a big big shift among smokers and
among drinkers in the last couple of
years in part we have to say thanks to
the government's very very sort of stern
anti drinking anti-smoking campaigns a
big shift towards the idea of harm
reduction and towards the idea that
these things have costs and benefits now
as a liberal I think that we should let
people decide whether the benefits
outweigh the costs to them but if there
is a demand for products that are lower
cost but still pretty high benefits
things like e-cigarettes or things like
synthetic alcohol and the industry could
wants to satisfy that demand there's an
incentive for them to provide better
products and to provide safer products
now what we're talking about today is
products that are superior in safety
terms so if you are a if you're a
business you can offer for example an
e-cigarette or some other kind of
reduced risk tobacco product that's
almost as good as a cigarette but
significantly safer then you will we
assume attract more smokers who care
about their health I think what we
should trust is in competition and in
the kind of legal mechanisms that we
have to punish firms that are dishonest
and so it's that kind of mechanism of
competition that I generally think
maintains standard
isn't the easiest answer for government
to simply ban things that are
detrimental to people's health certainly
government has a role in educating
people if that education isn't taking
place kind of privately I think perhaps
we go too far in the direction of trying
to scare people off and trying to sort
of our only metric is reducing the
number of smokers or reducing the number
of drinkers what I would like to see is
metrics that look at the benefits and
the cost people and check that people
know about the costs that they're
incurring onto themselves that's the
role for government really because when
it comes to adults we generally in a
liberal society think that nobody except
the individual themselves is equipped to
know whether the costs outweigh the
benefits what are your thoughts on
synthetic alcohol I mean that's that's
like a perfect example of innovation
that has come up against government
legislation isn't it yeah I mean
synthetic alcohol is a really
interesting example it reputedly does
the same thing to your brain that
alcohol does but doesn't do the same
thing to your liver to the rest of your
internal organs that alcohol does so it
causes much less long-term damage I
think that this should go through very
very rigorous checks to make sure that
these claims are actually true that's
not what the government is doing the
government is really just treating this
like it's you know poison and and not
giving it any kind of route through
testing through kind of an approvals
process where all we need to do is find
out what it does and then inform
consumers about what it does so that
they can make a choice for themselves
that's what I think the real key for
government is now is to create a
regulatory pathway it's from the point
of developing a drug like this to
testing it and to marketing it to
consumers that doesn't exist at the
moment finally I'm gonna speak to Chris
Snowden head of lifestyle economics at
the Institute of Economic Affairs I want
to know whether it is actually good
business for companies to innovate and
produce products that actually reduce
harm
should industry take a lead in
addressing public health concerns rather
than just waiting to be asked I think
when it comes to innovation in hazardous
product categories it's bound to be
industry lead away the government is
unlikely to come up with any novel
innovations itself the businesses have
got huge incentives there's a serious
demand for low sugar drinks smoking to
be made less hazardous for drinking to
be made safer so I think the basic laws
of supply and demand mean that
businesses will respond and it really
the only people who can respond is it
actually good business for companies to
produce products things like say
electric cars low-alcohol beer low fat
foods yeah there's a huge amount of
money up for grabs for any company that
can come up with something that reduces
the negatives from a product reduces the
risks reduces the cost whatever it may
be you know it's a basic cost-benefit
analysis if you can reduce those costs
in terms of health risks and the kind of
examples you're giving there you've got
a massive competitive advantage and
everybody else doesn't stop to follow
you
what about harm reduction should or or
can industry be part of the solution do
you think well there's various types of
tobacco harm reduction and if you look
at the most obvious and oldest one it's
nicotine patches and nicotine gum again
they came from business from the
pharmaceutical industry more recently
you've had swedish snus it's about our
origin of course e-cigarettes and other
products along the way such as heat not
burn so these have all come from
business primarily and I think it's only
natural that that it should do I think
obviously they have to have a part to
play I think they've got a very major
part to play because they're the ones
who have the know-how have the money and
have the incentives to do it
does anyone trust industry to be
unbiased in the research that they
conduct well I don't see why the
taxpayer should have to be paying for
businesses to do research it seems to me
that there are indeed should be
something that comes out of their own
budget and I don't think it's a really a
question of trust I think it should just
go through the peer-reviewed journals we
put up in front of the scientific
academy as you would any other and you
have a former research trust should
really be a part of
[Music]
for my conversations
it seems the industry does have a
critical role in harm-reduction and
public health initiatives the biggest
innovations in public health from
cigarettes to electric cars have come
from industry not government it's clear
though that these are only part of the
solution there has to be government
frameworks in place to enable innovation
and also the individual has to take
ultimate responsibility for harm
reduction
[Music]